prolibre bonsoir le juge d'instruction
jean michel lambert conformément à
l'inculpation prononcée en juillet 85
entre christine villemin persiste et
signe il persiste dans sa conviction de
la culpabilité de christine villemin
pour le juge il ya suffisamment de
charges pour renvoyer la mère du petit
grégory devant les jurés d'une cour
d'assises il a donc signé une ordonnance
de renvoi devant la chambre d'accusation
de la cour d'appel de nancy
quels sont les éléments du dossier du
juge lambert explications avec roland
sicard
c'est contre l'avis du parquet d'epinal
et de la chancellerie que le juge
lambert inculque christine villemin
d'homicide en juillet 1985 pour le juge
deux éléments de preuve principaux le
premier une incertitude de 15 minutes
dans l'eau près du temps de christine
villemin au moment du crime à l'appui le
témoignage d'un voisin
la voiture de la jeune femme n'était pas
dans son garage le jour du meurtre
pour le juge christine villemin pouvait
donc se trouver au bord de la vologne
quand son fils a été assassiné second
élément de preuve la cordelette que les
policiers de nancy découvre chez les
villemin de laboratoire arrive à la même
conclusion
c'est la même cordelette qui a servi
attaché les pieds et les mains du petit
grégory un faisceau de présomptions qui
conduit le juge lambert à faire
incarcérer christine villemin la prison
de metz en juillet 85 une incarcération
qui ne durera que douze jours
la chambre d'accusation de nancy ordonne
la mise en liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire de la jeune femme
le 16 juillet 1985 de son côté christine
villemin a toujours nié
selon elle elle n'avait pas le temps
matériel de tuer son fils dans les
quelques minutes où les enquêteurs
perdent sa trace
les enquêteurs qu'ils nous trouveront
d'ailleurs aucun mobile qui pourrait
accuser christine villemin
aujourd'hui le juge lambert a transmis
son dossier à la chambre d'accusation de
nancy c'est elle qui devra décider du
non lieu ou de la mise en accusation
devant la cour d'assises